this is a production of Cornell
University today I'm gonna talk to you
about some ideas I've been putting
together and starting to work on as part
of my PhD dissertation the goal of this
work is linking microbial substrate to
the formation of organo mineral
associations so both of these areas of
research are heavily studied by our
community and so my goal was to ask
questions trying to link these two
processes it's hard to find a nice
picture to sum all this up the best I
could do was a picture from some field
work recently so this is looking down on
the soil surface after we pulled away
the Oh a horizon you see these beautiful
fungal hyphae extending at this
interface between the Oh a horizon and
the more mineral-rich B horizon below
that you know how I advanced I can do it
manually on the research I've been
involved with in the past and how this
research led me in leading into my
dissertation questions and the Met
designs and I want to show you some
preliminary results from my first
chapter and then hopefully the outcomes
so as amy said before coming to Cornell
I was involved I was fortunate enough to
be involved in Alana's change project so
I was doing more ecosystem scale
measurements ecosystem auditor if you
will if you will we were looking at a
management intensive grazing grazing
dairy system after transitioning from a
row crop agricultural management system
so it was a lot of digging pits taking
multiple soil samples and filled with
cores and watching that change in soil
carbon and nitrogen
and so that work really led led me to
note the importance of human management
in sequestering soil carbon and nitrogen
and it was uh was more about you know
taking note of the stocks and not as
much about process based science and so
moving into my Master's I wanted to ask
more about ask more questions about
decomposition and what processes Drive
soil carbon nitrogen accumulation so
while I was doubly into the literature
for my master's thesis there was a lot
of papers coming out really stressing
the importance of microbial of the
microbial community in this process so
this is one paper I've chosen that
really stuck out with me and they pulled
out some back of the envelope
calculations that show that microbial
necro masks forty times greater than
living by them biomedicine soil so it's
really a graveyard out there in some
sense up to 80% of soil organic carbon
is microvilli derived and you've seen
inferences of the importance of
microbial biomass to soil carbon and
nitrogen preservation by a whole host of
measurements so if you look at studies
that look at different fractions of the
depth or denser fractions that tend to
be more mineral associated or fractions
that tend to have older ages by 14c
dating you tend to see evidence that
this carbon nitrogen is microbially
derived since they have a lower c2n
ratio a more enriched isotopic
composition which indicates processing
by the community and then spectroscopic
and biomarker analyses also indicate
that this carbon nitrogen has been
processed so I'm telling you all this
because it's important to have a better
understanding of microbial processing
understand the preservation of soil
carbon and so I picked these two figures
out for the paper cuz they really stood
out to me at the time when I was
introducing myself to the subject so
these I believe they are German
researchers gruesome E coli up in the
lab on 13 C enriched substrates so you
have enriched ecoli biomass and then
they just threw that out into an
agricultural deal and they followed the
fate of
carbon-nitrogen for several years three
or four years and you can see with time
over fifty percent of that dead biomass
still retains and in the soil matrix so
that's surprising because these are
compounds that you think would decompose
relatively rapidly and they attribute a
lot of this preservation as others do in
the field to sorption of this dead
biomass to mineral surfaces so also at
this time while I'm working on my
Master's it was kind of a there was a
conceptual framework put out that was a
reiteration of some ideas that have been
floating around for a while that really
changed how we viewed the the
persistence of carbon and nitrogen in
Plzen soil so you know your intuitive
approach to the topic is if you add
stuff that decomposes slower it should
stick around longer that's just the
intuitive view of the subject and what a
lot of authors are coming to to
understand is that when you really look
at longer time horizons you see an
inverse in this relationship and so
these more recalcitrant litters which
may have higher sita in ratio though
they disappear faster earlier on and you
look at longer time horizons there's
actually less of that recalcitrant
carbon nitrogen in the soil so the idea
here is that this material is used less
efficiently so I had long time horizons
it's not preserved so I wanted to you
know that's a great idea and all but I
wanted to test to see if I could see
that in in a laboratory incubation so
working in these dairy systems there's
this interesting opportunity I didn't
tell you much about the system but they
can really manage the age of the forage
which dairy cows are grazing so we had
this idea of could you choose an optimum
forage age at which you could enhance
not only carbon sequestration but the
preservation of that material by
minerals and so I intubated a range of
residue inputs ranging in quality and so
the white circles here are showing the
bermudagrass forage
and then we made fake manure from that
forage which is lower in quality and I
can tell you later how we made that
pretty interesting story and what I
incubated that in the lab at optimum
conditions and then we followed how much
of that carbon was remaining and how
much wood that was associated with
mineral fractions and what I found would
you look at the y-axis this is clay
associated carbon is that there was a
clear relationship that if you add
higher quality litters you see more of
that carbon associated with the clay
fraction than you do with lower quality
layers and a similar trend holds for
nitrogen as well though it's a lower
magnitude and so moving into my PhD I
wanted to continue looking into this
topic but at a much finer scale and at a
molecular scale and so to do that we
first have to think about what do I mean
by carving use efficiency I've said it
many times to do that I don't to use a
cartoon so don't cringe too much
microbiology people in life this is a
bacterial cell if you can imagine it in
the soil environment it's surrounded by
all of these compounds that it might use
to grow right but a lot of these
compounds can't assimilate as they are
right they're too large to transport
across the membrane and so do
polymerization reactions are needed to
cut these larger molecules into smaller
monomers or dipeptides smaller molecules
of membrane but so at any one time you
can think these low molecular weight
compounds make up about 10% of the
carbon and nitrogen in solution so
they're a very small fraction
and you can imagine also that some
microbes may not have ability to produce
the extracellular enzymes to
depolymerize these larger molecules but
anyways there's a small fraction that's
readily available to the microbe and it
may choose one substrate to grow on it
may sequentially move through low
molecular weight substrates as it grows
and it may use several substrates
simultaneously and during that process
it produces more biomass and it respires
in the in the process some of these
substrates are assimilated and used to
produce more biomass produced reducing
equivalents and get that proton motive
force to do these reactions and so if we
want to think about how efficiently the
carbon is used to make new biomass we
can simply calculate the carbon in the
microbial biomass versus the amount of
carbon that is moved through the system
in this process so the amount in the
microbial biomass plus the total
respiration so the size of this red
arrow and then there are some
interesting inferences we can make about
how carbon you sufficiency might change
with temperature or with substrate
concentrations and also maybe most
importantly with phylogeny so this is my
fungal cell please don't cringe we can
think of it as part of a - maybe yeah we
tend to think that these fungal
organisms can use a wider range of
compounds to grow so they have more
metabolic diversity right and when they
grow they tend to grow more efficiently
so they produce less co2 per unit
biomass so that's carbon use efficiency
but then we can also think about
substrate going back to this bacterial
cell if we could follow just one
substrate maybe with an isotopic label
then we can partition out how
efficiently that wants us so we can
follow the label of the carbon from that
fuko's for instance
into the biomass substrate your
sufficiency so that gets interesting cuz
here we're not looking at much at total
metabolic efficiency we're really at are
these compounds being assimilated more
versus dissimilar and predicting how
these compounds may be used is an
interesting idea and some people have
thrown away thrown out different ideas
on how to do this and one idea that
seems promising is using the nominal
oxidation state of that card so this is
kind of an average of the oxidation
state of all the carbons in that
molecule so you can imagine I have nos C
on the x-axis here and on the Left we
have carbonate an oxidation state of
four so that's the most oxidized going
to the most reduced you know co2 for
example versus methane and with
decreasing oxidation state you actually
have a higher heat of combustion so you
have more energy in that compound and
then we can think about where is biomass
and on average microbial biomass is
around negative 0.2 so it's slightly
more reduced than the average sugar and
so if you're building biomass from
compounds that are more oxidized than
you are then your energy limited right
so you can convert that carbon into new
biomass but the second law of
thermodynamics really prevents you from
using that carbon completely efficiently
because you don't have enough energy to
generate enough heat right to to
compensate for the entropy you're losing
by making new cells on the other side if
you're using carbon sources that are
more reduced your carbon limited so you
have enough energy but you can't produce
that that biomass is officialy so then
we can look at where different compounds
are on this gradient you know
unsurprisingly organic acids are more
oxidized right a lot of the sugars and
amino acids range closer to the
microbial biomass and then membrane type
compounds tend to be more reduced
so then we can look at some data from
microbiology literature so these are
single isolates growing on one carbon
source and you can see this trend where
as you get further away from the biomass
oxidation state you see a decrease in
carbon use efficiency so right if you
squint your eyes you can see this trend
approaching the average oxidation state
of the biomass and then maybe on the
reduce side you see downward trend or no
relationship so that's looking at carbon
use efficiency with one substrate but
then we can also look at additions of
substrates to the soil matrix so this is
substrate use efficiency it's tracing
one compound and from these two papers
we can see a similar trend in soil
environments where these more oxidized
compounds or use less efficiently and we
don't have much data on the reduced side
but perhaps that's a decrease or perhaps
there's no relationship so so that's an
introduction to carbons and substrate
use efficiency and now I want to talk a
little bit about mineral surface
sorption and the kinetics of those
processes and thinking mostly about the
mineral surface as a competing
repository for these compounds versus
the microbial violence so this is some
data from a lab mate of mine Mike
Schmidt came out this year and this is
kinetics absorption and so here we're
looking at DNA sorption on to ger type
so on the x-axis we have time in minutes
and on the y-axis we have Q so this is
from FTIR data but you can think of it
as the surface loading of this DNA and
the point I want to make here is first
of all with increasing initial DNA
concentration so with higher
concentrations of compounds in solution
you can get more on the surface so
anyone who's done sorption isotherms
realizes this point you can get higher
loading rates with more organic
compounds in solution
higher concentrations and then the
second point I want to make is the
kinetics of this process are a function
of the saturation deficit so it's a
function of how far are you away from
saturation under those conditions
so maybe sounds a little esoteric if you
look at this bottom line we think of
this one DNA concentration solution at
time zero you have the highest
saturation deficit possible right refer
this from equilibrium as you can be and
that's where your heist kinetics can be
found and as you approach that
saturation point things slow down slope
of this line and more importantly as you
increase the Q max possible at
equilibrium you see those kinetics
increase as well right so if you have a
higher Q Max looking at this green line
you have higher initial kinetics right
you can see that there's a much higher
slope initially so what I'm pointing out
here is that saturation deficits really
drives how well the surface can compete
for these low molecular weight molecules
and so then you can try to think about
well win might a microbe out-compete a
mineral surface for these compounds it
needs to grow right so early on kinetics
are really high if you have a high
saturation
so maybe the mineral surface can
out-compete them like if you're already
at saturation close to it there's a
higher chance that the microbe can
out-compete the mineral surface to get
these you can think early on that
perhaps metabolism isn't as important
because the mineral is out competing the
microbes to sort whereas in these middle
phases understanding how efficiently the
microbial metabolism is processing might
increase in importance because it can
help compete the mineral surface and
there's still some there's still some
saturation deficit left right so if it
does process that carbon efficiently
there's still room for that biomass to
be stored after the fact and in the last
days you're already at Q max so if you
efficient if you metabolize the
substrates efficiently or not
does it matter because none of its gonna
stick pregnant in simple terms so I
think my goal moving into this into this
work was to devise model system
experiments to tease out these different
questions in isolation and try to use
those results to build up to a model
soil then I can then ask these questions
in an actual soil environment so to show
you one more schematic I'm looking at
how different how efficiently different
compounds whether the clay fraction or
the biomass and how compete which one
can win this competition for these
substrates and then lastly does the
saturation deficit so how much loading
of organic material is on this track
clay fraction does that influence the
importance of substrate use efficiency
in determining carbon and nitrogen
loaded on the mineral surface so for my
hypotheses I think I think that nominal
oxidation state may be a useful tool to
predict how efficiently these compounds
are metabolized and I think the shape of
that bell curve may change depending on
the phylogeny of the organism you're
talking about for uptake kinetics I
think mineral surfaces will out-compete
at higher saturation deficits so when
they have less carbon and nitrogen
loaded on their surfaces and then lastly
I think differences in substrate use
efficiency will only be important at
middle saturation I've talked about a
lot of things here in the abstract and I
think it's important to kind of bring
this into a real contest so I'm trying
to build these model systems but I'm
trying to build them in the context of a
soil profile so I chose a field site at
Arnett Forest
it's a hemlock hardwood dominated course
in
with an inset the sole below it the
earthworm's haven't gotten here there's
a pretty thick Oh a horizon still and
then you have a pretty shallow a maybe
an e horizon slowly forming on top of
analytic dominated the horizon and so
this is the real-world context on
building these questions and the idea is
I'm in some way simulating the pulse of
a rainfall event so organic rich soil
solution percolating downward where you
have this competition between mineral
surfaces and the microbial box for my
soil solution I'm making a tea if you
will from this Oh a horizon so I've
homogenized it something try to
replicate this process I shake it with
water for a specified period of time and
then I filter sequentially till it's
sterile so I've made a undefined media
to grow microbes in and then what I've
tried to do it's not easy as trying to
define that in as many ways as possible
right so I can do crude measurements of
total carbon total nitrogen and
phosphorus measure reducing sugars amino
acids and then right now I'm using
proton NMR and HPLC mass spec to
quantify individual
it's not as easy as making a defined
minimal media that the moving from there
I need some microbial players to work
with obviously I'm not going to capture
the diversity of microbial species in
the soil but you have to start somewhere
so I've isolated species from the Oh a
horizon and the B horizon and then the
main idea here is I'm trying to separate
for fungal versus bacterial eyes it's a
crude distinction but once again I'm
trying to get physiological differences
in phylogenetic differences and so I've
isolated those on my soil extract so
I've tried to get real players that
would hopefully respond with this
percolation event so with that I've got
a a an isolate library
I think there's around 12 of these
isolates and currently working with I
was really proud of those twelve
isolates till one day I was talking to
Roley and he was like I've got 56 or
something but I have several them I know
are fungal and several I know are likely
bacterial they represent a simple sugar
and glucose some organic acids and two
amino acids and then the goal here was
to span that nominal oxidation state to
choose some that are more reduced on
average versus others that are more
oxidized right with formate this is
basically a co2 ready - and then from
mineral phase I extracted the clay
fraction on this the horizon
so it's analytic dominated clay fraction
and I have cleaned it with bleach which
is apparently the least destructive way
to clean so I shake it I've shaken it
with bleach and tried to remove as much
of that surface so now I want to walk
you through the experiment experimental
methods I'm using to determine substrate
use efficiency I'm growing different
isolates of interest in this soil
solution I grow them to exponential
growth phase and then I can use that
starter culture to inoculate
experimental flats and so the way I've
designed this is I add a low molecular
weight cocktail with all of my
substrates of interest and then only one
is labeled so you can imagine in this
experiment every flask should be growing
at the same on the same trajectory and
the gross carbon nitrogen the only
difference so in a you know in a second
treatment I would have a different and
the idea here is I'm spiking around two
times the original concentration so I'm
trying not to change things too
drastically and then I can measure co2
over the course of growth and then at
stationary phase I can filter out the
biomass and measure total biomass as
well as the isotope in that biomass so
that allows me to measure carbon use
efficiency and substrate using dishes on
top of that I'm also doing uptake
kinetics because I'm interested in how
in what substrates are being a blast
what order and at what rate so it's the
same design but there is no label added
and then I'm destructively harvesting at
different points along the growth curve
so then I can look at uptake from the
extracellular solution for the mineral
I'm doing batch kinetic studies as well
as batch equilibrium studies hopefully
producing data similar to that of mics
that I showed you so the goal here is to
look at the kinetics of total carbon and
nitrogen sorption from solution as well
as looking at looking at that data in
terms of individual compounds so here's
where I can look at competition between
microbial uptake in mineral sorption
so here's a picture of this clean clay
and the idea is from the batch sorption
experiments I can look at saturation
behavior at different soil solution
concentrations at equilibrium so then I
can also determine for this third
experiment how to load that clay out to
different saturation deficits so for the
final portion of this project the goal
is to take the data from the first two
experiments and see if I can replicate
that in a real soil so when I'm using
real Lucy I'm mixing that clay fraction
which I will load up to different
saturation deficits with clean sands and
then I'm spiking in that soil extract
along with my isolate of choice and
different substrate treatments and so
the goal here is to see okay I have two
substrates that are used with vastly
different efficiencies does that matter
in a real soil environment does that
impact the amount of carbon nitrogen
that is retained by the mineral fraction
and does mineral surface loading impact
that process either so for this portion
I want to show you some data from
genetic experiments I've been conducting
so to do these experiments I chose one
isolate of interest
it's just be one in and that just means
it was isolated from the B horizon on
just soil extract it's a [ __ ] so
bacillus organism and I chose it simply
because it produces the most biomass so
I figured it was a good place to start
and so to refresh your memory I'm
growing this overnight in a starter
culture and then sampling along the
growth curve and then I'm measuring
carbon and nitrogen before filtering and
after filtering so that allows me to
estimate carbon and nitrogen in the
biomass and then on the filtered
solution which is the extracellular
material I'm looking at carbon nitrogen
nitrogen speciation as well as different
substrates using these methods so this
is the growth curve I'm showing time and
hours versus optical density and so like
you may have learned an intro
microbiology you can measure growth just
by measuring changes in humidity and you
see a nice growth curve I haven't shown
the fit past stationary phase so you'll
just have to take my word for it but
stationary phase is around point two in
this soil extract and I've tried to hit
different points of this exponential
growth so anyone in the room who's upset
I'm showing this as optical density 600
I'm just showing you with my different
measurements I can easily convert that
number to biomass so I have a linear
relationship with total biomass being
abused as well as carbon and nitrogen in
that biomass or a more traditional assay
approach so now I want to talk about
solution dynamics I will start with
nitrogen so I'm nitrogen in milligrams
per liter versus time in the blue we
have total nitrogen so this is outside
of the cells we're starting at around 12
milligrams per liter of nitrogen and
then you see an uptake or loss of
nitrogen from outside the cell its
growth and so I haven't shown a mass
balance but there's no loss of nitrogen
from the system so this uptake is or
this loss from solution is uptaken
system and you see that looking at
biomass nitrogen in the red you can see
all that nitrogen loss from solution is
ending up in the biomass and by the end
of growth you have about equal amounts
of nitrogen in the cell
nothing surprising here and then I'm
showing loss of amino acids as well as
ammonium during growth so to start with
we know this microbes growing it's
consuming amino acids in ammonium as it
grows if we look at carbon same thing
we're looking at extracellular carbon in
the blue so in milligrams per liter
about 185 to begin with we see loss of
carbon from solution that's as it's
taken up in the biomass in red I can
calculate co2 produced by difference and
then also just at the crudest level I
can see I'm losing reducing sugars once
again not surprising this microbe is
growing on sugars in this soils so
here's where it gets interesting I can
then take these samples into proton NMR
on them to try to get compound specific
information and so this is a method
that's being used quite a lot in minimal
media work where you have higher
concentrations it's a little easier to
do or in medical applications or
engineering work I've seen it with like
biofuel research trying to figure out
metabolic pathways so
have to do is I have to take this soil
extract you can concentrate at 30 full
because I'm right at the detection limit
so and then I get this spectrum so I'm
showing chemical shift here on the X
intensity is arbitrary here
and I got this data from the Cornell
chemistry unit and I was very excited
about it and they thought it was the
worst section but the goal here is I can
choose Peaks that are not overlapping
with other compounds and then I can
integrate them and compare them to a
standard to quantify them and so the
real beauty of NMR is I don't need a
standard for every compounds I can use
one in terms any compound so I've shown
you some you know I don't know what this
aromatic compound is I there's a bunch
of sugars here some amino acids organic
acids and then I can look at that
through time and you can see you can't
see the peaks very well here but you can
see it the depletion and all the peaks
and so I can choose individual compounds
and look at that depletion
show you my best example right so this
is my one of my glucose seats it's for
alpha glucose so if we look at the
glucose molecule we get a proton NMR
signal from this behind a proton on the
fine group right here the number two
carbon and that's a doublet and as you
can see the initial soil solution is
this dark line and what time the line
gets lighter and we see a loss of that
sugar from solution so I can integrate
this area and quantify that out into
micro moles of glucose and you see this
nice sigmoidal uptake curve and so
that's a good start right that matches
with my expectations and then not only
that it's in the right magnitude so I'm
looks like I'm probably doing this right
right so the red curve is total reducing
sugar so that's multiple triggers and
this is just my glucose peak and I
should say this flucos piece is peak is
the is the alpha glucose plus the beta
glucose so that's one example and then
where this gets even more interesting is
I can fit that sigmoid 'el uptake using
a four-point sigmoidal curve and so I
can extract a t-50 value so that's the
point at which half of that compound is
being Absolution and then also I can get
a usage width and then I can convert
that to whatever I'd like but what I
like to show is 90% and 10% of compounds
so here's an example for ammonium right
I can pull out a t-50 value and again
Cheers so what gets interesting is I can
then overlay that on the growth curve
and start to think about in what order
are associates being used by this
microbe and so here are some early
examples from this NMR work where I can
see that baylene and threonine are being
used much earlier than glucose glucose
is being used later than the average of
all the sugars so there are some sugar
is being used earlier than glucose and
then what gets interesting and this is
maybe an aside for my main questions is
also intrigue to think about can we
predict substrate use efficiency just by
where it is used in the growth curve so
we look at the same experiment I can
calculate carbon use efficiency shown
here on the on the y axis with time and
you see an increase in carbon in
cumulative carbon use efficiency with
growth so this microbe by stationary
phase to use the carbon with about 40
percent efficiency but if I calculate
the instant power use efficiency over
these intervals you see that looks
somewhat like maybe a bell curve right
so there's this idea that maybe the
compounds being used right at the
inflection of growth are being used most
efficient which gets interesting because
that means I should be able to predict
the substrate use efficiency just might
be what order those compounds so that's
a little is another question from
thinking about so moving forward I'm
conducting this similar experiments for
my fungal isolates I'm conducting the
isotope work right now with the
different substrates and then using this
data to hopefully build up to that final
model soil so the outcomes of this work
is to test the role of phylogeny and
carbon you sufficiency test the
predictive power of nominal oxidation
state or predicting substrate use
efficiency and then also testing the
impact of saturation deficit on the
formation rate of these mineral organic
associations so I think all of that
summed up is when is microbial
metabolism important for the formation
of these mineral organic associations
and then lastly there's some hope that
this may provide some guidance to
modelers none of these parameters would
be directly usable by a model but it may
give some guidance on the magnitudes of
these parameters and the relationships
and some of you are thinking that's
crazy who models at this scale and
people do this is a model from do-e
where they're explicitly trying to build
in
fungal versus more heterotrophic aerobic
bacteria and modeling specific compound
classes so I think my interest is to so
look at this scale I question that this
scale and try to provide parameters
towards those who are thinking at this
scale so with that I'd like to
acknowledge you guys for bearing with my
lab group in a marked facility the
Buckley lab and my funding sources so
thank you very much yes I would very
much like uh I would hopefully do 16s or
18s I don't know physically how I when
you have your framework those sort of
more oxidized or more of these compounds
and sort of your hypothesis is based
you know the metabolism and the
efficiencies can change occupations and
then you're kind of setting up the
experiment to prove that by having
different substrates right or at least
to see you know season matches
expectations but if you took a different
approach and tried about falsify it by
doing something like having a molecule
that the organisms might have different
efficiency for but maybe
oxidation-reduction doesn't change like
glucose and cellulose right nd the
oxidation reduction is the same but the
microbes ability to encounter that and
use it is going to be dramatically
different so if if you found very
different carbon use efficiency on
glucose versus cellulose with that no I
think it would just
let me try to
so first of all that's a good point
and I think you see that in some of the
data we are so if you look closer to
microbial biomass you see there's a
bigger range right and that's some of
those compounds you're mentioning so no
I think I don't think that falsifies I
mean you're looking for a predictive
proxy that may not work in all cases but
I'm looking for a general trend of can
this be used and some kind of modeling
framework right so no I think I would
just say that things are not as simple
as this obviously so when you so
company's efficiency can be problematic
and I think the issue that problematic
is the timeframe at which you assess it
you know so if you assess it in a very
short window you're measuring one comma
and if you measured it in a longer
window of time for a very long period of
time but you're actually measuring is
cheating quite a bit whether its
physiology or interaction cells were
actually ecological interactions you're
measuring it at a really short timeframe
I think it's really neat but my question
was this so so if you had so your
expectation is you've got these
equilibrium processes you're eating the
substrate you're converting it into co2
and biomass so what if you violated that
assumption so what if your amino acids
are going directly in the protein right
they're not going in the co2 they're not
being used to make ATP what if the
glucose is going directly into a storage
product it's not going the co2 it's
actually consuming ATP and then maybe
this great product being used later on
so since you're doubling time is four
hours you're measuring these things
scale of hours you know might you be
having differences in efficiency because
you know the cell is using these amino
acids just to make protein or it
speaking sporadic how might that affect
your results so I think what you're
describing is trying to redo the
experiment but spiking at different
points in the growth curve is that well
you're seeing carbon use efficiency airy
and you're kind of saying
well you know maybe they're growing more
efficiently on this substrate versus
that substrate and maybe it's not that
they're growing more efficiently it's
maybe they're storing more carbon and
disappointment that one it's not about
efficiency so much as it's just these
reproductive choices in the cell you
know instead of doing balance growth I'm
actually making more storage products at
this point and I'm not and because
you're looking at this carbon ease
efficiency at a very granular measure
you know it looks like though the
company's efficiency is going up and
down but in reality you just have non
equilibrium processes happening I think
I follow you I just don't know how I
would try to think of how to probe that
experie what I mean
I guess in my millennial you mean -
simulate this pulse of it right so you
you know you might think why don't you
do this and chemostat setting and the
ideas that's not how things tend to work
right you have this pulse event and then
you have rapid growth because wow
there's all these substrates available
all of a sudden so in some sense that's
what I'm trying to mimic and I guess
maybe maybe even test it with a more
defined medium instead of a soil extract
so you grow them on glucose amino acids
and if you have a systematic difference
with one versus the other than it's
telling you that oh okay I see what
you're saying I think there is some
evidence looking at single you've got a
storage pool within the microbes so you
might also be able to do some other
experiments and just some kind of
input-output modeling right you might be
able to estimate the size of that
storage pool or measure it in some way
so you can actually answer it well yeah
this might be happening but it's only 5%
you know or yeah this could be 90% get
it some idea that's what it is sort of
saying instead of like this instead of a
straight line it's like this you know
where if you average it looks like a
straight line but there
really granular level in stepwise and so
depending on where you if you sampled at
this point versus this point it might be
low or high present example at a really
poor scale if you wanna use mineral
weird an exaggeration model if you know
you've brought up some up up yet another
account where it's working space that
will be occupied by my back to my school
so looking at this model I'll pull it up
so this model it's not even they haven't
even put the minerals on the where it is
but it's in there and all they have
think it's it's it's initialize based on
the amount of clay in the soil and then
they just have a forward and backward
rate there's no modeling excites no so
at this point I'm thinking about this
more I'm not even bringing in I'm just
thinking if you thought about these as
separate players in the system thought
about competition so there's all also
these other concepts where just because
something sorb doesn't mean a microbe
can't kick it off by exerting another
compound right like exerting a phosphate
rich compound that could in these are
back compound and allow that substrate
to be utilized yes I would say so any
other question
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu